awad bergström ist eine von etwa einer
million schwarzer menschen in
deutschland so ganz genau weiß das aber
niemand es gibt keine offiziellen zahlen
aber bergström ist als tochter
sudanesischer austauschstudenten nach
der wende in leipzig aufgewachsen
ostdeutschland in den 90ern das war
schwierig für schwarze menschen viele
fühlten sich allein gelassen
ein rechter mob im jahr jahrmarkt um 1
steht und da steht ein polizist und
letztes über ein geschehen
30 15 personen auf einen einbringen
das ist das sind schon erinnerungen die
halt haben einen oft noch zweifeln
lassen ob man tatsächlich erwünscht ist
in diesem land
it's one teach one und cds of europe
führen daher eine umfrage durch den
abriss sensors es ist die erste zur
lebensrealität schwarze menschen in
deutschland
daniel jammer hofft die umfrage kann
wissenslücken füllen
leider gab es aber in den letzten jahren
und jahrzehnten viel zu wenig forschung
über die situation von schwarzen
menschen zu anti schwarzen rassismus
das führt auch dazu dass die politik
immer wieder zu uns kommt und sagt ja
was ist denn das problem gibt es euch
überhaupt sie tun sich schwer von
schwarzen menschen zu sprechen
und deshalb haben wir gesagt wir nehmen
das selber in die hand boka im sender
stammt aus frankreich und arbeitet als
lehrerin in berlin
sie ärgert sich über den mangel an
sensibilität auch bei manchen
wohlmeinenden weißen meine klasse und
ich habe ein lied vorbereitet in die
kinder waren sehr motiviert aber dann
bekamen sie lampenfieber daraufhin dreht
sich der schuldirektor zur versammelten
schule und sagt ich liebe einfach
schwarze musik sie nicht auch und ich
denke nur interessant das problem und
die eigentliche frage ist woher sie es
besser wissen sollen wenn es keine
zahlen gibt keine aufzeichnungen und
niemanden der darüber spricht
der affront zensus soll genau diese
diskussion ermöglichen und
alltagsrassismus in der deutschen
gesellschaft besser
fassen doch es hat auch noch einen
anderen effekt das ist auch sehr empire
und letztendlich für diejenigen die
schwarz sind und deswegen finde ich das
super
eine umfrage wie den afro zensus hat es
bisher noch nie gegeben
deutschland sträubt sich gegen die
statistische erfassung der bürger nach
ethnischen kriterien auch aus
historischen gründen es gibt immer immer
wieder die angst dass wenn man
communitys befragt was eigentlich ihre
situation ist ob sie diskriminiert
werden dass man durch diese forschung
diese communitys erst kreieren würde
wir sind aber hier ich sitze hier auf
dieser bank wir sind teil dieser
gesellschaft wir lassen uns nicht
verleugnen und wir können ruhig über
schwarze menschen afrikanischen
menschenaffen menschen sprechen ohne
angst davor zu haben
der afro zensus könnte also einen echten
fortschritt für die afrodeutsche
community bringen